the US government is racing to evacuate
Americans from Wuhan as China sends
medical reinforcements to the city where
the deadly coronavirus outbreak began
officials there say the virus is now
spreading faster so far it's killed at
least 81 people in China more than 2,700
others have been effect infected across
13 countries five of those cases are
here in the US Ramey Inocencio has been
covering this story from Beijing after
leaving Wuhan last week rainy how are
people there reacting sure a good
morning well China's Health Minister ma
Xiao Wei has said that he expects
infections to continue to rise and of
course that has everyone here in the
country even more nervous now get this
Wuhan and at least 16 other cities with
a population of more than 50 million
people are still on some kind of
transport lockdown and we spoke to one
American stuck in Wuhan and he says that
panic is starting to rise the biggest
problem is I just wish I could get my
family off where we need to go to
America American Justin steez and his
wife Ling have lived together in Wuhan
for the past year and a half just three
weeks ago Ling gave birth to their baby
boy colm my biggest fear is that I would
go out get sick not knowing it and then
come home and spread it to Ling and the
baby Steve was a soldier in the National
Guard for five years but his wife
doesn't have a US visa yet and he can't
leave Wuhan to finish her paperwork
otherwise I would have evacuated with
the rest of the people and gotten oh I
think it out here he and reportedly 1000
other Americans are now stranded as the
Chinese government works to contain the
deadly virus within its borders but as
quickly worked its way around the world
this case poses no immediate threat to
the general public on Sunday Los Angeles
County officials tried to reassure the
public they weren't in danger after two
more cases in the US were confirmed one
there and one in Maricopa County in
Arizona all while the number of
infections worldwide continues to climb
back in China the epidemic has even
forced the government to extend the
massive Lunar New Year holiday by three
days so officials have more time to work
and to keep people from contracting and
transmitting the virus at ground zero of
the epidemic in Wuhan excavators are now
working around the clock to build two
hospitals to treat the infected and food
reserves are being sent in as near empty
shelves line supermarkets but for all
the government's efforts Steve says
they're not making anyone feel any
better with the Chinese government
saying oh it's calm resolute um the
citizens are actually freaking out more
than normal and the State Department has
said it is chartering a flight to
evacuate Americans out of Rohan Justin
though will not be on that flight who
will be it'll be US consulate staff as
well as some American citizens who will
be paying their own way and earlier I
was in touch with US Embassy here in
Beijing and they told me that all those
people on that plane should expect to be
screened once they land in San Francisco
Tony you certainly feel for those people
trying to get to safety Remy Inocencio
for us in Beijing ramie thank you very
much